[Music]
well summer is the season of road trips
and we're packing up the car and heading
out to show you a few places you'll want
to check out a new series called vegas
drives now first up if you need a quick
getaway with a family that's less than
two hours away jc has an idea for you
who's ready for a road trip today we're
going 90 miles south of town to laughlin
nevada for what this is something very
special for the entire family come on
it's an easy drive just head towards
boulder city take the 95 south to the
163 east and if you get hungry you can
stop in searchlight stop here at gus's
jerky it's delicious
[Music]
welcome to laughlin nevada where you can
do gambling you can go to the spa you
can go golfing there's water activities
but today we're here for something very
special don laughlin's classic car
museum and this is brian he runs the
place good to see you buddy nice to meet
you
[Music]
brian i gotta tell you it's great to be
here it took me 90 minutes to get down
here i'm a car lover so this is extra
special for me how many cars do you have
in the museum over 50 over 50. let's
take a look because what i love about
driving to laughlin it's an easy day
trip where do you guys get all these
cars from they're from people that just
want to put them on display
other people want to consign them and we
sell them
i'm i like this super the super b you
have right here in the color too it's
plum crazy the color jumps out to you
you guys are open seven days a week open
to all ages this is open seven days a
week all ages what i like to about it's
air conditioning insiders yes
nice and comfy how many people do you
have coming down from las vegas to visit
it depends what's going on down here
yeah i mean we can have
20 people here we can have 100 people
through a day while visiting be sure and
say hi to bud one of the museum's
curators i told you i'd bring it last
year yeah i sure have one so i wanted to
bring it to you oh thank you very much
thank you
but what a witness seemed very special
what just happened our customers brought
in their packs to put on the board for
the police equality and i'm proud to do
this for everybody and if you can see
look at this this is from all across the
country firefighters and policemen they
send you their their packages yes sir
well once you go ahead and put it on the
wall so it's more than just cars here at
the classic car museum
what a special moment
don laughlin's classic car museum is
sure to bring back great memories and
certainly create new ones
good stuff jc thanks to centennial
hyundai for sponsoring that segment las
vegas now we'll be right back